have you ever done crowd work and
realized in the middle of the guys were
the prostitute no I have I've been like
hello sir that's your date she's looking
sparkly
what's your name of Mercedes wait a
minute like I'm moving on
[Music]
what do you do I've also done crowd work
to a pregnant woman smoking way before I
had you know any authority you got to be
the headliner to tackle that one oh yeah
the opener can't be like Hello
you're giving your feet Milwaukee and
they were first of all they're smoking
inside it was too thick yeah I mean I've
been doing some of you right I mean long
enough for the smoke inside remember
when people would blow smoke at you
my least favorite oh and I used to I
used to host at the improv so this is
like 1989 and you could smoke there and
I would be there from 8 o'clock till
1:30 in the morning and I would come
home and it was like I had five packs of
cigarettes that's that's a great
Seinfeld joke too he goes like I
secondhand smoke five packs a day
because I sit next to someone on a plane
that has smoked and it's on their jacket
and I'm coughing do you want to get real
fancy-pants yes a makeup artist smokes
oh and Here Come their yellow tar
fingers right to your eyeball and you're
like thank you very so mad as you said
can you wash your hands are kinda stinky
sure enjoy the next 40 minutes and yeah
they just ate like a sauerkraut sandwich
absolutely it's so gross and I can't
believe we all put up with it for so no
dude I worked at Bennigan's we used to
work in the smoking section the Monte
Cristo is already gonna kill you do you
have to send a pack of Kools in chasing
after I love the whole concept of the
smoking section like the smoke didn't
reach the non-smoking section it's like
the air section and I'd be in the oxygen
section well there's oxygen cuz i
remember smoking on the plane really I
mean I smoked you know my mom when I was
a kid gave me five bucks
to not smoke when I was like six years
old Wow for some reason I felt like I
needed to honor that just made me tear
up I don't know what that is so sweet
because that does do something to you as
a kid I'm being paid for jobs I'm making
in five dollars as a kid is a lot that's
a great sister she struggled to quit
smoking always she went to this thing
when I was a kid called smoked Enders my
mom went to smoke and ER yeah and what
it worked was yet to get
like you know like glass thing and she
would put all cigarette butts in it and
there's water in it and it's stunk yeah
and then she would have to try to sniff
it before she decided to smoke to be
disgusted by a great idea it didn't end
well look I don't smoke but if I could
go back in time and light up a cigarette
on an airplane I would I would do
it I would get up just like a man in the
70s I'd unbuckle my pants just for the
relaxation just kind of let it flap
smoke a cigarette
call the stewardess sweetheart come on
but there was like a smoking section so
usually was like the back of the plane
and they'd have like the little curtain
and the assumption that the smoke wasn't
gonna just be a cylinder oh but on
madmen they smoked in first class you
can't you can't have a little section in
the back and not have the Prima's in the
front I bet you'd add like half of the
first class smoking and half of coach
okay yeah I mean it was all ridiculous
how could he sleep if the guy next to
you was just sucking down a marble
because it was everywhere yeah you're
right everywhere right I grew up smoked
inside and I had chronic sinus
infections as a kid I had like a line in
my nose from always going like this it's
just one of those kids that's just
constantly and we go what is going on
what are her allergies turns out smoking
yeah of course cut to me cascading my
baby with a humidifier that looks like
an elephant like we've changed so much
like the idea hey Duncan get over here
bring the ashtray like your little five
year old stay here daddy's ashing and
you feel like you know I'm 34 it wasn't
like I was a kid in the 50s when it was
the GM but still there were just
egregious mistakes being made as parents
that they didn't know any better I know
my wife was just on a plane and she said
she was sitting across from a rabbi who
was vaping painting on the place
although this is a weird sorry that's
not fully related but my daughter Maude
was on a plane and she's like I said
next to this guy and like everyone kept
walking up to him and asking for his
autograph and I didn't know who it was
who's mr. T one of the easiest
autographs by the way three letters and
you don't use that period just like you
up your no punctuation so we're going
you don't need punctuation who's the
most famous people you've been on
airplanes you know I have a good one
about this because I got on a plane and
Paul Giamatti got on and he sent it
right next to me then ten minutes later
Tom Selleck got on wow
so I'm looking he smells like leather
and burgundy and I leaned over to put
Paul Giamatti and I go I'm so sorry I
never do this we'll talk to Paul
Giamatti when he sits next to you no you
know I feel bad but that story's not
true everything except what I said is
not I said behind Nancy Reagan but I
will tell you what was truly the reason
I because I was like I was so determined
not to talk to Paul Giamatti
even though crashing season 3 January
20th yes shoots on the same stage as
billions and we have a lot of the same
crew so I knew I had it but guess who
has restraint I don't need Cookies
afternoon and I don't bother Giamatti I
was on a plane with Alan Thicke once and
there was an enormous amount of
turbulence and I thought and then I
wasn't nervous I'm like it's not gonna
happen with Alan Thicke that's funny you
just had a feeling but that's not how
you're going down Tarantino had that on
a turbulent plane and he was writing
Pulp Fiction he goes I haven't finished
my movie I was on a plane when I was a
kid with Freddie Prinze did he have a
baby with him though was he smoking hey
sweetheart
he calls you sweetheart hey sweetheart
France I mean and as a huge comedy fan
early on were you freaking out did you
go yeah I was little but he was a giant
star then yeah and there's an episode of
crashing that we ended with the theme to
cheek
the man and it's my favorite music you
I've ever put really anything for some
reason it's just so perfect at the end
of the episode
do you guys struggle with turbulence
still with all the traveling I was on a
plane I think we're gonna crash every
time mm but I was recently on a plane
and there was all this turbulence and we
were in first class because HBO was
flying us out it was really fancy and
nice and the guy next to me I was trying
to be good they kept offering us like
ice cream sundaes and liquor and I was
trying to be good because we were about
to shoot I was like no no I'm good and
the guy next me I was hating this guy
and he whenever I turned down something
he'd take mine yeah so you had two ice
creams to champagne then he got really
drunk then he started watching like
rampage or something and then he
reclined to seat before takeoff I don't
care for that above the rules no I know
I hate when you know someone's gonna get
told something and he was it because he
was passed out full of Darian Delors and
he's just breathing in a way that I knew
he had an apparatus at home and this is
still turbulent he doesn't care he's
passed out and then he wakes up in the
middle of flight and on unpause his
rampage with his socked foot and that's
when I went we can crash I will happily
die I will be the Jesus Christ at this
plane I will die so the world doesn't
have to have this man I feel that way
the sound of his sock on the screen
there for the next person smelling like
a bowl full of wet cigarettes that would
have made your mom stop smoking if he if
he handed your mother's cigarette with
his socked foot my mom did eventually
quit she went to a nunnery to like
isolate and learn to quit smoking and
then she also read my book the alan carr
book the easy way to stop smoking that's
everyone yeah oh wait I just talked to
his last name Dan Soder so sodor told me
about that book I can I know he told me
yes yeah he was like you gave him that
book I read a book called this naked
mind the easy way to control drinking
and it's like it Alan cool and I quit
drinking what have you been hypnotized
about everything what my personality
really and its
anxiety everything people like your
goofy face like that sort of stuff but
he gets intense you know he's all back
he he's like if you couldn't make a deal
with God and in that deal you would
never get sick and you won't die in a
hospital suffering and pain from disease
and all you had to do was eat well would
you make that deal and then I go
straight to sprinkles you're having the
session in a sprinkles not to be afraid
on a plane as I just it's when I get on
I accept my own death I just go I swear
every time we're like that's a good rule
for life yeah I just go you know what it
was a good ride I think we did good and
then and then we take off and like it is
we're afraid of being on planes right
because planes might crash but we're all
stuck in these planes you know you're
never not on a plane like this could
have a failure there's just no engine
light I could so this is actually a good
point making peace and living in the
present is the see I used to get on
planes and go it was actually a Bill
Cosby joke unfortunately he used to say
I won't do the voice okay are afraid to
fly but when I get on a plane I don't
even hide it I just go hope but don't
crash right so every I used to get on
planes obviously I've been on thousands
of planes and I used to in my head go
hope it don't crash just to make the
same little joke yeah and now I just go
I'm grateful for the present moment and
that really takes it away because I'm on
a plane right now there's nothing to say
you could be scared or you could
appreciate I'm not trying to frighten
anyone I'm trying to make your breakfast
taste better sometimes I think you're
only breakfast but I also think that
your body is so soft that sometimes I go
it's just weird that more things don't
bump into it and just cut off a huge
hunk of it I know like play-doh
like the way that play-doh could be cut
with like knives your whole life you're
just trying not to get something to bump
into you and like lop off a hunk of your
head what if you go back to ancient
Greece and you're like I'm looking for
Plato and they're like over here fresh
morning okay we're doing Plato in the
morning my makeup artist played with
play-doh and my makeup and be stay close
to my childhood
I love you did you have a sauerkraut
sandwich with the other hand she's just
taking play-doh breaks oMG play-doh
Cologne Nicki why not I just made a
billion dollar idea for us neither of us
have to work every you sneaker Cologne
okay they have that they have puffs that
is definitely wearing a sneaker Cologne
I don't know if it's for sale but he's
definitely turtle from Entourage is
definitely
[Music]
you